The desert is still.
The night seems endless, silent, and at peace…
until it’s pierced by the sound of gunshots
and screams.
Deep in the Sahara, the SCP Foundation is
waging war against a newly discovered enemy.
A squad of foundation agents is retreating,
trying to get away from the ones who massacred
their allies.
They were attempting to eliminate the threat
using conventional means, but their rifles
were no match for the reality bending entities
of the Kingdom of Abaddon.
The retreating agents cover one another as
they make their way back to the extraction
point.
The enemy force advances.
Agents that are caught too close to the sorcerers
of Abaddon disintegrate into thin air.
This is not an enemy they can defeat.
The SCP agents need to get back to base and
relay what they have found to their superiors.
Out of the hundreds of agents sent into the
Sahara that night, only a handful make it
out alive.
They are debriefed by their superiors at the
Foundation who classify the anomalous humanoids
under the highest of threat levels.
The Kingdom of Abaddon is a threat.
The Kingdom of Abaddon must be eliminated.
Reconnaissance done prior to the disastrous
mission had alerted the Foundation to the
presence of anomalies in the region, but they
had no idea how strong the anomalous humanoids
would be.
From data gathered through old reports, it
seemed that the Abaddon humanoids were responsible
for the deaths of no fewer than 75 Foundation
personnel, and had stolen at least 12 different
items from the Foundation.
The leaders of the SCP Foundation tasked research
team Omega-5 with developing a weapon that
would be capable of destroying the Kingdom
of Abaddon once and for all.
The weapon they are researching must be capable
of long range destruction, because the moment
any Foundation agent gets close to the area,
they are vaporized by the reality manipulating
powers of its inhabitants The project is given
the name “Twins of God” and is led by
a Foundation doctor known only by the designation
“O5-1.”
O5-1 is popular in the SCP Foundation, well
known for his in-depth research and charismatic
personality, making him the perfect person
to lead such a project.
And O5-1 recently came across an anomaly that
he believes holds the solution the Foundation
has been looking for to defeat the Kingdom
of Abaddon…
Item-001.And so the Omega-5 team gets to work.
They discover that the anomaly has incredible
powers when put inside a host, which they
refer to as an Item-001 entity, and set up
a series of experiments using different people
to harness its energy The first series of
tests all end in tragedy.
The anomaly causes the entity it inhabits
to become intensely radioactive.
Anyone who gets close to it succumbs to immediate
radiation sickness, and eventually death.
To stop the radiation problems the Omega-5
research group intensifies the containment
procedures.
O5-1 receives reports from the higher ups
that the Kingdom of Abaddon has attacked another
Foundation facility in Sudan.
Long-range defense is needed A.S.A.P.
The administrator puts more pressure on Omega-5,
and especially its leader O5-1, to solve the
problems of Item-001 and develop a weapon
that can save the Foundation.
He stays awake for days on end, working tirelessly
to create a safe and controllable Item-001
entity.
Although there are signs that the weapon will
work, it is still unpredictable.
When Item-001 is initiated, the host entity
becomes paralyzed, suffers severe cerebral
hemorrhaging, and soon a new host is needed
before testing can begin again.
And that’s not the only thing going wrong.
Whenever the anomaly is put into a new host,
sudden and random destruction of on-site structures
and personnel takes place.
O5-1 knows though, that if this power can
be harnessed and controlled in the right way,
that it could be the weapon that the Foundation
needs to wipe out the Kingdom of Abaddon once
and for all.
In order to control Item-001, O5-1 has a mind-kill
switch implanted in its hosts’ brains.
O5-1 can activate the implant to incapacitate
the host and immediately stop the unwanted
destruction.
Countless hosts are terminated by this mind-kill
switch in the early trials conducted by the
Omega-5 team, but progress continues to be
made and eventually a hypothesis is formulated.
Perhaps the disastrous side effects of Item-001
can be offset by spreading the anomaly across
multiple subjects.
They theorize that the immense mental load
of the anomaly can be distributed among several
hosts, thus reducing the toll it takes on
each and giving them the ability to control
its immense power.
But O5-1 and the Omega-5 team need more data,
and for that, they need more bodies.
They consult with the director of Site-17
and it is concluded that the nearby town of
San Marco would be an appropriate place to
get the additional test subjects they require.
On a quiet Sunday morning, Omega-5 along with
support from a squad of armed SCP agents storm
into the San Marcos de la Vida Sterna Church
during the middle of mass.
They gather up a number of the younger congregants
and bring them back to the site where Item-001
is housed.
The researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though, and Omega-5
would need to get even more if their research
was to continue.
Instead of going back and forth between the
testing facility and San Marco, O5-1 decides
to move the entire Item-001 operation to the
town itself.
He renames the town, Testing Site-001, and
Omega-5 rounds up 23 of the healthiest subjects
they can find for use in the next series of
research tests.
A few weeks after occupying the town of San
Marco, Omega-5 makes it’s most substantial
progress yet.
Just as they theorized, by spreading out the
anomaly of Item-001 across a specific group
of hosts, they can control its powers.
The tests may have cost the lives of almost
everyone in the town, but the ends certainly
justify the means.
The Kingdom of Abaddon poses an existential
threat to the SCP Foundation after all, and
thanks to this research they will soon have
a weapon capable of bringing them victory.
The Foundation administrator criticizes O5-1’s
methods, but can’t argue with his results.
Unfortunately, O5-1 has a dark secret.
A secret that disturbs even the most hardened
and loyal members of Omega-5.
A secret that has to do with the Item-001
hosts.
The hosts that Omega-5 has made its major
progress with are not the ordinary test subjects
normally used by the Foundation.
No, the test subjects O5-1 makes his breakthrough
with… are children.
Nine of them to be exact, all between four
and eleven years old.
Despite being told specifically by the Foundation
administrator to only test on adults, the
research required O5-1 to break the chain
of command and follow the science down the
path it led.
The children are contained in a reinforced
bunker where only O5-1, and a select few,
have access.
They are technically alive, but are functionally
brain dead.
The group of nine children share a hive mind
that can process information, and more importantly,
can unleash the full potential of the implanted
anomaly, creating and controlling a devastating
power.
But not everyone is thrilled with what they’ve
achieved.
Members of Omega-5 are haunted by the screams
of the children that they’ve forced to be
part of their weapon development program.
They describe their merging with Item-001
as being a process that rips out their souls
and replaces them with something much more
sinister.
In fact all of Omega-5 regret what they have
been a part of and what they’ve done, all
except O5-1.
The nine children can channel unprecedented
amounts of energy from an unknown origin that
Omega-5 hypothesizes comes from an extradimensional
source, which is then used to unbind atoms
at the quantum level.
When the right activation words are spoken,
it appears as though this tremendous power
gives the children the ability to annihilate
anything in the entire universe.
It’s the gun to end all guns.
And only O5-1 has the key to control it.
The nine children work so well within Item-001
that Omega-5 reclassifies it to include the
nine children themselves.
They are not just the entity housing or controlling
Item-001, they permanently become Item-001.
Once Omega-5 has a better understanding of
Item-001, they begin to run tests to find
out the full extent of its abilities.
First they test the distance Item-001 can
reach.
The initial test that Omega-5 carries out
is on a steel rod placed 5 kilometers away.
O5-1 orders the children to destroy the target.
Moments later the phone next to O5-1 begins
to ring.
When he picks it up the observer tasked with
watching the pole is on the other end.
He informs O5-1 that the steel rod has been
completely vaporized.
O5-1 is not satisfied though.
He has another pole set out, this time placed
8,000 kilometers away from the nine children.
O5-1 asks the children to destroy that rod.
Almost immediately, the phone rings again.
The target has been vaporized.
O5-1 smiles.
The next series of tests Omega-5 runs on Item-001
are to determine the maximum size of an object
that can be destroyed.
The tests start out with a steel sphere, 3
meters in diameter, placed 1,000 kilometers
from Item-001.
O5-1 orders the children to destroy the object.
It is instantly vaporized.
O5-1 has seen enough small tests.
It’s time for something big.
So he does something that will later be questioned
by everyone at the SCP Foundation.
He orders the nine children to destroy a Church
of the Broken God worship site in Turkey.
Not long after the destruction order is given
to Item-001, reports begin coming in.
The worship site has been obliterated with
no observable damage to the surrounding area.
Deadly and precise.
O5-1 closes his eyes and takes a deep breath.
He looks as if he is overcome by an immense
spiritual experience.
He opens his eyes, leans over to the children,
and whispers the name of someone.
Later that day, O5-1 finds out that the target
he had named has been vaporized.
The success of Omega-5 and Item-001 is relayed
to the administration of the Foundation.
They are so impressed that they make plans
to use Item-001 to eliminate the Abaddon threat
once and for all.
However, one of the heads of the foundation,
Administrator Williams, has major concerns
about the way O5-1 is running the program.
The updates that O5-1 has been sending have
become less scientific, and more philosophical…
more… spiritual.
Administrator Williams sends a letter to O5-1
reassuring him that he is doing good work,
but once the mission to destroy the Kingdom
of Abaddon is completed, O5-1 will be promoted
to director, and reassigned to the newly constructed
Site-19.
For the good of the Foundation, and maybe
the world, he’ll be permanently moved away
from Item-001.
O5-1’s response is short and to the point,
“I am fine, Administrator.
The project is finished.
We will complete our task when you arrive.”
Administrator Williams arrives at Site-001
a few days later.
He is greeted by O5-1 and the Omega-5 team.
Williams can’t help but notice that O5-1
has a strange look in his eyes.
It is the look of a crazed man who has been
lost in his work, and who has, perhaps, lost
himself.
Williams puts the thought away though and
walks with O5-1 and his accompanying agents
to the viewing area where the powers of Item-001
will be demonstrated.
Administrator Williams and the other agents
watch from a protected viewing room as O5-1
enters the chamber of his new super weapon.
It’s time to see if their weapon that has
had so much time, effort, sweat, tears, and
especially blood poured into it, will have
been worth it.
Everyone watches as O5-1 leans over and says
the name of the Abaddon Citadel to the nine
children.
All at once, they start to glow.
No one observing can see what has happened
in the far off Kingdom, but they know something
big has happened.
The administrator is thrilled, but notices
something.
O5-1 hesitated a moment while leaning over
the children before standing back up.
Did he whisper something else to them?
And then Administrator Williams vaporizes,
pulled apart at an atomic level before he
has the chance to scream.
What’s going on?
The agents standing next to where Administrator
Williams previously existed begin to yell
and pull out their guns.
They burst through the door of the observation
room and run down the hallway towards where
O5-1 and the nine children are located.
The armed agents rush into the room, but O5-1
is gone.
The nine children are still.
Over the next few weeks O5-1 is reported to
be seen several times by SCP agents.
However, no one is able to catch him, and
it appears as though other members of the
SCP Foundation have also gone AWOL as well,
perhaps joining him on the run.
It is unclear what his plan is, but reports
from the reconnaissance team sent into the
Sahara make it obvious what the result of
his first command to the children was.
There isn’t a single humanoid or building
left in the Kingdom of Abaddon.
But even with this victory, the highest levels
of the SCP Foundation have an ominous thought
lurking in the back of their minds.
Where did O5-1 go, and what is he planning
to do next?
Following the improper use of Item-001 leading
to the untimely death of a high ranking Foundation
Staff member, the weapon was deemed too dangerous
and containment procedures were implemented.
Due to the high amount of radiation they were
found to emit, the nine children were placed
into lead lined bags and buried under 50 meters
of concrete beneath the church of San Marcos
de la Vida Eterna.
Though all of the children continue to be
functionally braindead, they still display
signs of life despite their containment, and
by order of the Overseer Council, have been
classified as a Thaumiel entity.
The smell of fire and oil fills the air.
The sound of gears grinding can be heard between
the explosions and shrieks of terror.
A man runs out of his house, only to have
his leg grabbed by a metal arm and dragged
back through his front door.
SCP-001 leaves a trail of metal fragments
and mechanical parts on the ground in the
wake of its destruction.
Iron chains swing from its form, cast iron
gears whirl within it, a glowing light throbs
form the center of its body.
SCP-001 is consuming everything in its path.
After incorporating the truck chassis into
its being, SCP-001 rolls in a lumbering fashion
to the next house.
It rips the gutters from the side of the building.
Residents who live in the area flee their
neighborhood.
All the while hoping that the mechanical monstrosity
skips over their house so they have something
to return to if they make it out alive.
A section of SCP-001’s undercarriage drops
away from the main body.
It rolls down the street consuming more and
more material.
The new entity resembles a human spine and
rib cage.
It topples over unable to support itself.
The rib like formations extend out to grab
anything and everything within reach.
The newly incorporated material forms what
can only be described as a head.
Light from within the eye sockets fixate on
nearby civilians.
The metallic creature picks up the people
and places them inside its exposed, steel,
rib cage.
Then it turns and spots a woman helplessly
trying to crawl away.
The creature reaches out with a spiked tentacle
and wraps it around the woman’s body.
She is placed inside of the chest cavity.
Moments later a severed hand falls out of
the entity and onto the ground.
The mechanical monster continues to gather
bodies and materials, incorporating them into
its frame.
A growth begins to slowly expand on its back.
It becomes so massive that the creature falls
over and uses its limbs to scurry into a nearby
house.
There is a sickening crunching sound as the
growth bursts.
From within emerge three humanoid creatures
resembling the civilians that the entity had
consumed earlier.
A female with chains extending from her scalp
like dreadlocks stumbles away.
The second humanoid is a man with cogs for
limbs.
He examines the clock-like components that
have been incorporated into his body, then
stares blankly into the distance.
The third humanoid lies motionless on the
ground.
He did not make it.
The two functioning humanoids look at their
creator intently.
For a moment nothing moves, then as if they
have been given orders telepathically, the
half human half machine humanoids turn and
run away from the mayhem.
A few weeks before the massacre caused by
what would be designated as SCP-001, the Foundation
had been in contact with the Allied Occult
Initiative.
There were rumors of an anomalous object in
Mexico being worshipped by a group of people
who identified themselves as The Church of
the Broken God.
Intel about the Church claimed their deity
was a small mechanical box filled with cogs
and pistons.
The box supposedly had supernatural abilities,
it was said to be able to communicate with
congregants of The Church of the Broken God
telepathically.
The devout worshiped the box, following any
order it gave, and in return they were filled
with an emotion that could only be described
as divine.
As World War II rages on in Europe, the Foundation
sends agents to recover anomalies in Mexico
that might help with the war effort.
While there, the Foundation force is tasked
with learning more about The Church of the
Broken God.
They are also ordered to investigate a town
near La Paz where there are troubling accounts
of a mechanical anomalous creatures causing
mayhem.
The agents make their way through Mexico gathering
various objects to bring back to Foundation
sites in the United States.
The unit loads all of the anomalies they’ve
recovered onto a train with the plan to check
out the stories of the mechanical anomaly
they’ve heard about as they make their way
to the U.S. border.
The train heads north along rusted rails.
Just outside of La Paz they come across a
broken down train filled with what looks to
be refugees.
When the Foundation unit goes to investigate
they find all of the refugees repeating the
same words over and over again but they don’t
understand.
The Foundation agents look at one another
confused, until one of them translates the
words into English.
The words the refugees are saying over and
over again are “la máquina, la máquina…
the machine, the machine,”
The commanding officer orders a squad of Foundation
agents to proceed up the tracks, to see if
they can figure out what has the refugees
so scared.
They make their way towards La Paz, disappearing
over the horizon.
As the sun sets the remaining Foundation agents
hear gunshots in the distance.
They stay awake all night remaining vigilant,
waiting for the exploratory squad, but morning
comes without anyone returning.
Three days later, the Foundation force still
has not seen anything since the exploratory
squad left.
Then as the sun sits lazily in the morning
sky, a lone figure is spotted walking down
the tracks towards the trains.
One of the agents on watch blows his whistle
and points to the figure.
A squad of agents rushes towards the shadow
of a man.
Their guns are raised, ready for anything.
The figure drops to the ground and begins
to crawl along the tracks.
The agents reach the fallen man, only to find
that he is one of their squadmates who had
been sent up the tracks to investigate La
Paz several days before.
The agent’s name is DeMarco.
He is covered in blood.
His clothes are in tatters and he has lost
a boot.
DeMarco lies on his back with Foundation agents
standing around him, his eyes are wide and
wild.
He keeps babbling on about a “world eater,”
how the rest of his squad had been mulched,
and he is the only one who made it out alive.
The Foundation agents carry DeMarco back to
the makeshift base they created by the trains.
They need to figure out a way to get the convoy
moving again, but whatever is up ahead has
taken out an entire Foundation squad.
It had to be something anomalous, but what
could it possibly be?
The unit of Foundation agents prepare to move
towards La Paz.
They start loading their rifles and check
the amount of ammunition and explosives available
in case the containment process gets out of
hand.
Just as they are about to leave the base,
a convoy appears on the horizon.
It is an Allied Occult Initiative force preparing
to attack whatever it is that is devastating
La Paz.
This organization’s mission is not to secure,
contain, or protect, but to destroy.
The Foundation may be in over their heads
on this one, and the joint force with the
Allied Occult Initiative may be the only way
to stop what is now known as SCP-001.
The AOI and Foundation force gears up for
battle.
They set out for La Paz, and what they find
causes them to quake with fear.
SCP-001 has consumed so much material it is
the size of a mountain.
It moves like a tidal wave of mechanical destruction,
washing over the buildings and landscape under
it.
Whatever SCP-001 passes over is consumed and
added to its massive body.
SCP-001 started as a small mechanical box
with cogs, but now has morphed into a gigantic
metal death machine.
The Church of the Broken God has finally met
their maker, as the small entity they once
worshiped has now consumed all of its members.
Their god is an all consuming monster.
The AOI and Foundation forces do everything
they can to stop SCP-001 from continuing its
reign of destruction.
They fire barrage after barrage of bullets
and explosives into the mechanical anomaly.
They bring in air support to try and damage
it from the skies, but nothing works.
The AOI uses an artifact in their possession
to lure SCP-001 to the coast of the Pacific
Ocean where a trap has been set for the so-called
god.
The monstrous mechanical creature moves slowly
towards the water.
It consumes abandoned cars, buildings, and
boats as it approaches the coastline.
It even shovels large amounts of the earth
into its form, causing flames to spurt out
from its inner workings.
Smoke bellows from openings between different
mechanical components, like a volcano before
it is about to erupt.
Suddenly, seemingly from nowhere, a massive
cloud with a reddish tint appears in the sky.
Air raid sirens can be heard in the distance.
The enormous cloud begins to pulsate.
Streaks of lightning shoot through the red
mist in the sky.
It now sits directly over SCP-001.
From within the cloud part of a ship can be
seen.
It appears to be slightly damaged, electricity
flows over its hull.
The vessel in the giant red cloud is classified
as SCP-2399.
The underside of the vessel begins to glow
aqua blue.
A blinding beam of light is ejected from SCP-2399,
which penetrates straight down and through
SCP-001.
For a moment everything is still.
There is complete silence.
Then as if SCP-001 is trying to reach up and
grab the vessel above it, a mechanical bulge
reaches out.
Before SCP-001 can grab the vessel above,
there is another bright flash of light.
SCP-2399 blinks out of existence.
The sound of grinding gears can be heard coming
from within SCP-001.
It begins to shed its outer layers of metal.
Then the entire structure that was SCP-001
collapses into the water and onto the beach.
Giant cogs fall from the sky.
Parts of vehicles embed themselves in the
sand.
As the Foundation and AOI agents approach
the piles of scrap metal and mechanical components
they see that some of them are still moving.
It is as if an invisible powersource is still
pulsating through some of the machinery.
The agents of the Foundation celebrate the
destruction of the giant mechanical beast,
but little do they know this was only a piece
of the entity worshipped as the Broken God.
The Foundation agents collect as many of the
still moving parts as they can.
They find spinning gears, twitching pulleys,
and firing pistons.
As the parts are separated from one another
and carried away from the main wreckage of
SCP-001, they slowly stop moving and become
inactive.
Some of the artifacts recovered were identified
as being connected to the Church of the Broken
God.
These artifacts are found closer to the middle
of what was once a mountain sized SCP-001.
Hundreds of anomalous artifacts are collected
and transported to SCP Foundation sites.
Collecting the broken parts of SCP-001 is
relatively safe.
However, some agents get too close to the
larger moving parts, getting caught in them
and losing a body part or two.
But most agents proceed with caution and survive
the collection ordeal with their arms and
legs still attached to their bodies.
Dive teams are sent into the water to recover
parts that have sunk to the bottom of the
sea.
One of the divers is a local from the area.
He is hired to bring up the heart of the machine,
since he is an experienced diver used to free
diving to great depths to collect oysters
from the bottom of the bay.
The diver enters the water and swims down
into the murky depths.
He secures straps around the heart of SCP-001
and pulls hard on the rope, as an indication
to the surface that it is ready to be hauled
up.
The salvage team on the surface begins to
pull.
There is a second slight tug on the rope,
then it goes slack.
The team continues to pull.
When they get the heart to the surface they
are horrified at what else comes up with it.
Tangled in the ropes is the lifeless body
of the diver.
His head is smashed between two moving pieces
of the heart.
It looks as if he shoved his head between
the slabs of metal himself.
The salvage team untangles the body, rolls
it off the deck, and back into the ocean.
The mechanical box which was the heart of
SCP-001 is offloaded onto the shore, but as
the Foundation prepares to move it to a containment
facility, the weather starts to deteriorate.
Hurricane force winds sweep across the water
and batter the coast.
The heart is kept in a secured storage warehouse
until it can be moved.
The people living in the village nearby complain
of hearing voices and rashes so itchy that
they practically tear their skin off.
Once the storm passes, the Foundation agents
load the heart onto a ship.
It is to be transported to a Foundation site
just across the border.
The ocean seems calm and serene.
The Foundation ship undocks and begins its
journey up the coast.
Not too long after beginning its journey the
ship slowly drifts off course.
It is as if the crew has stopped manning their
posts, and the ship is being controlled by
a mind of its own.
The Foundation ship crashes and sinks somewhere
in the Pacific Ocean, never to be found, and
more importantly, the heart of SCP-001 doesn’t
make it to the Foundation site.
Years later a man is walking along the beach.
He hears something.
It sounds like someone pounding on a large
drum to the rhythm of a heartbeat.
The man walks towards the sound.
Something is drawing him forward, closer and
closer to the heartbeat.
He walks and walks until the beating stops.
He bends down and moves the sand aside.
He spots the corner of a mechanical box sticking
out of the white sand.
The man digs deeper and pulls out the small
box.
Inside he can see gears whirling and pistons
firing.
He holds the box close to his own heart.
It seems to speak to him.
The man brings the box back to town.
He starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area join the new religion.
They cast aside their old beliefs and focus
on the powerful entity contained within the
box.
God is not dead… at least not yet, but the
prophecies of The Church of the Broken God
say that when the heart is found, the God
will reassemble itself once again.
Then the Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities, until only he remains.
It’s a quiet evening at Area-11 where the
Pietrykau-Fontaine Spatial Stabilization Array
is housed.
A skeleton crew is working overnight, to ensure
the array is ready for its big test the following
day.
The Foundation has been working on a particle
accelerator that will contain anomalies with
the ability to manipulate the nature of spacetime.
The preliminary tests seem promising, but
a few last minute tweaks to the array are
necessary.
Unfortunately, it is on this night in 1982,
that marks the beginning of the end for the
SCP Foundation.
Dr. Calvin Desmet is monitoring the array
and he notices as it spools up that there
are some minor power fluctuations in one of
the stabilization arms.
This problem is not uncommon due to the vast
amounts of energy being pumped through the
array and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off, which slowly causes the coupling
rings to loosen.
Calvin Desmet decides that remounting the
stabilization rings will be an easy fix.
And it’s a necessary one.
He knows that if the rings fail during the
actual test, the array could end up shut down
for months.
There is still plenty of time, so Calvin Desmet
grabs his toolbox and heads down into the
array.
The machine is still spooling, keeping the
energy flowing at a constant low rate.
There is no danger at the moment, as the inside
of the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer ring.
But then something unexpected happens.
The system’s primary generator begins to
fluctuate uncontrollably.
A catastrophic failure is imminent.
Sirens begin to sound, the facility is evacuated
and the chamber is sealed.
Deep in the bowels of the array Calvin Desmet
cannot hear the evacuation announcement.
The humming of the array echoes through the
chamber, dampening all sound from the outside
world.
The array begins to come online while Desmet
continues to work on the coupling.
He has no idea what is about to happen.
Meanwhile a team of Foundation scientists
scramble to get the power fluctuations in
the main generator under control.
As they frantically work, catastrophe strikes.
They initiate the power-down cycle, but as
the generator struggles to keep the power
flow balanced, an energy surge builds up.
A massive amount of energy is released all
at once causing the main reactor to explode.
The entire structure rocks back and forth
and Desmet is thrown into the side of the
array.
He too now knows that something is very wrong
and runs for the exit.
When he reaches the door he finds it has been
sealed.
In a panic Desmet continues running through
the tube to the next access point.
This door has been locked as well.
He’s never been so scared in his entire
life, and he shakes uncontrollably from the
adrenaline being dumped into his muscles.
The surge of energy rushes through the array
towards Desmet.
A singularity begins to form in the containment
chamber.
The array is working just as it should, except
that there was never supposed to be a person
inside as the singularity was brought into
existence.
Moments after the singularity forms, the massive
pull of its gravity causes the stabilizer
arm that Desmet had been working on to fail.
The side of the array is ripped off, and Calvin
Desmet stares into the naked eye of the singularity.
Everything is silent and still for a moment,
then the singularity collapses in on itself,
taking the test chamber and much of the research
wing with it along with Dr. Calvin Desmet.
Sparking wires hang from the exposed walls
and ceiling where the singularity ripped the
main structure away.
Water flows into the deep hole carved out
of the earth where the array once stood.
The scientists from Area-11 look into the
crater left by the collapsed singularity.
The Foundation administration sends agents
to collect the staff at the site and document
the failings of the project.
They conclude that the accident was caused
by human error.
They order the array to be rebuilt, this time
using entirely automated systems to eliminate
the chances of another mishap occurring.
Several years after the catastrophic event
at Area-11 a new array is constructed.
An intelligence system called NETZACH is put
in charge of overseeing its functions.
It is a super computer that is programmed
to follow commands, but can also autonomously
make decisions in order to prevent any failures
in the system.
Experiments begin again in May of 2006.
The new array soon manifests its first singularity
in the containment chamber at Area-11 and
what happens next will forever change the
Foundation… and the multiverse.
The singularity is kept stable in the array,
it seems as if the Foundation has succeeded
in trapping and containing spatial anomalies.
But as they run more diagnostics on the anomaly,
something unexpected happens.
The singularity begins to grow in size.
The point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the boundaries
of the array.
Just before contact, the singularity’s growth
slows, and then stops.
NETZACH has made the split second calculations
and adjustments necessary to contain the singularity.
The artificial intelligence has saved the
facility and the lives of everyone in it.
Now, sitting in the array, is a thick rotating
cloud of radioactive gas and dust, obscuring
the singularity within.
As Foundation scientists work rapidly to fix
the array, odd events begin to occur.
The workers hear noises that sound like painful
wailing.
Over time the noises evolve into words, and
then full sentences.
They seem to be originating from the singularity.
Using equipment able to penetrate the thick
cloud of radioactive gas, the Foundation scientists
get a glimpse at the singularity.
To their surprise, the singularity has taken
on the shape of a human.
The scientists work frantically to figure
out how the singularity could have formed
itself into a humanoid shape.
Dr. J. Barton Ramsey is the first to try and
make contact with the humanoid within the
singularity.
He finds that the entity cannot communicate
in the traditional sense.
The massive gravitational pull of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape its void, instead,
the entity manipulates gravity to vibrate
the suspension rings of the array itself and
create soundwaves.
The being in the singularity whispers in a
metallic voice created by the vibrating of
the array’s rings and says “Johannes Ramsey.”
Dr. Ramsey steps back from the observation
window.
“How do you know my name?” he asks the
entity.
The humanoid within the swirling gas cloud
identifies itself as having the memories of
Calvin Desmet.
It is not Desmet per se, the being in the
singularity is so much more than one person,
but it was somehow created by the accident
that had sucked Calvin Desmet into the singularity
years before.
The entity seems to switch between the mind
of Desmet and the vast infinity of the cosmos.
The Desmet entity asks for an Overseer from
the Foundation to be brought in.
It has a proposal for the O-5 Council.
When Dr. Ramsey asks why the entity needs
to talk to the The Overseers it replies that
it wants “to offer them a way out.”
The following day, O5-1 enters the facility
and heads to the observation deck.
He looks through the reinforced glass at the
swirling cloud of radioactive dust, then glances
at a monitor to see the humanoid shape of
the singularity within.
He presses the microphone button on the console
and addresses the entity.
“To whom am I speaking?” he asks.
For simplicity sake the entity tells O5-1
to refer to him as Calvin Desmet.
O5-1 makes notes of the events unfolding before
him and then asks about the way out that Calvin
had mentioned.
The air is still for a moment.
Then Desmet begins to speak through the vibrations
of the structure once again.
He informs O5-1 that what the SCP Foundation
is doing by securing and containing anomalous
entities around the world, is like putting
a small Band-Aid on a much bigger wound.
Desmet wants to propose a final solution to
all of the Foundation’s problems.
O5-1 listens intently as the entity unravels
the mysteries of where the SCPs have come
from.
He explains that the anomalies that the Foundation
has worked so hard to secure, contain, and
protect the human race from are actually bleeding
into their reality from a vast multiverse.
The only way to stop the manifestation of
anomalies into this universe… is to destroy
all other realities.
The entity that is Calvin Desmet tells O5-1
that he is able to bring about this destruction…
if they release him from the confines of the
array.
O5-1 is transfixed by the swirling gas that
is promising him, and everyone else on Earth,
salvation.
He shakes his head in disbelief.
Could this be true?
O5-1 turns away from the swirling gas and
begins to walk away from the viewing glass.
“I’ll need to think about what you’re
saying.”
The structure begins to shake slightly.
The voice of Calvin Desmet reverberates off
of the array a little louder than before.
“Choose quickly Overseer, although it won’t
happen for decades, eventually a catastrophic
SCP event will wipe out life on this planet.
Perhaps not in your lifetime… but it will
most certainly happen within the lifetime
of your children.
We will talk again soon.”
The vibrations slow and then stop completely.
There is an eerie stillness in the observation
room as O5-1 walks out.
The next day all staff members located at
Area-11 are relocated to other Foundation
sites and given amnestics.
The O5 Council meets in a large circular room
with wood paneling and no windows.
O5-1 begins the meeting by telling the others
what Calvin Desmet had described about the
end of the world.
He pauses for what seems like an eternity
and then tells them of Desmet’s offer that
he could prevent the end of the world, but
at the cost of destroying an infinite number
of other realities.
This would mean that all the humans and creatures
of those realities would be destroyed as well.
Was murdering countless other beings worth
it to protect their own reality?
O5-1 begins to shake, he hasn't slept or eaten
anything since his talk with Desmet.
He's being torn apart from the inside.
O5-3 stands up and addresses the council.
He informs everyone in the room that independent
teams have conducted research into what the
Calvin Desmet entity has claimed… and they
found it to be true.
The world really would come to an end.
Furthermore, the research teams determined
that the capabilities of Desmet would in fact
allow him to dismantle the other realities.
O5-3 insists that the council must vote to
allow Desmet to destroy the other realities
to ensure that this reality could be saved.
They must strike now, before the world is
overrun.
O5-1 continues to shake while O5-3 breathes
heavily, sweat pouring down his temples.
The rest of the council shifts their gazes
from side to side.
It is time for a vote.
There are eight “ayes” to allow Desmet
to destroy all other realities and four “nays”
against the plan.
O5-3 stands and walks around the room, stopping
behind each “nay” voter and putting a
bullet in their head.
He stops at the last, O5-9, who pulls out
a gun, places it under her own chin, and pulls
the trigger.
O5-13 abstains from the vote and the measure
passes.
The remaining Overseers will use the Calvin
Desmet entity to save their reality at the
expense of all others, and they soon head
to Area-11 to execute their plan.
O5-1, 4, and 12 enter the observation room
that looks upon the swirling radioactive gas
around Calvin Desmet.
O5-1 orders NETZACH to begin powering down
the array, which will allow the entity to
prove he can do what he has promised.
They have pinpointed the reality that SCP-884
came from and the shaving mirror itself sits
on a table in another room in the facility.
O5-3 stands in the room, watching the mirror
to see if anything happens.
O5-1 asks Calvin Desmet to eliminate the reality
that the mirror had come from.
The room shakes as the entity uses it to acknowledge
the request.
Moments later the phone rings in the observation
room, it is O5-3, he informs the others that
the mirror has disappeared.
Its reality has been destroyed, and therefore
it no longer exists.
There is a sigh of relief in the room as the
Overseers realize that this just might work.
O5-1 asks Calvin Desmet to continue and destroy
all the realities that are bleeding into their
own.
This time the entire facility begins to quake.
Suddenly, O5-1 jerks backwards, his eyes wide
in confusion and horror.
His body seems to be compressing under an
unknown force.
O5-1 begins to distort, his legs and arms
fold into the core of his body.
His head snaps down, and all that was O5-1
is sucked down into a single point in space
before it completely disappears.
Calvin Desmet then turns his attention to
the other two Overseers in the room who both
seem to collapse into blackholes of their
own in the center of their bodies.
NETZACH's warning klaxon begins to sound,
signalling that the emergency failsafe has
been activated.
Before Calvin Desmet is brought under control,
the structural supports in the entire facility
vibrate with his words.
They are in a voice that sounds strangely
similar to O5-1’s.
“Your children are free to live lives that
do not end in horror.
An end to your perpetual struggle.
An end to darkness.
The freedom to live in the light.
All traces must be removed.
This world must be washed clean.
The Foundation does not escape atonement.
It is the only way out.”
It had been a deception.
The Calvin Desmet entity had no intention
of stopping anomalies from infiltrating this
world, it wanted to remove all traces of the
anomalous from all universes including this
one, and that meant destroying the Overseers
and the Foundation itself.
Their destruction would serve as an atonement
for the pain and suffering they had caused
in their quest to secure and contain the anomalous.
Calvin had to lie to the Overseers about the
real plan, since he knew they’d never sacrifice
themselves and the foundation, even if it
meant an end to anomalies plaguing our world.
Now though, with the Overseers out of the
way, the Calvin Desmet entity is free to move
forward with its plan and purge all realities
of any trace of the anomalous.
But just then NETZACH’s failsafes kick in
and the Pietrykau-Fontaine Spatial Stabilization
Array subdues the entity's abilities.
Desmet is once again contained.
O5-3 bursts through the door and into the
observation room.
He stands before the shattered glass of the
window that looks into the array.
O5-3 asks NETZACH how long the containment
array can hold Calvin Desmet.
The computer’s voice fades in and out but
says, “Given current conditions, one-hundred
and nineteen days, six hours, and forty-seven
minutes.”
O5-3 sighs, he tells NETZACH to make a note
in the SCP database that the Calvin Desmet
entity will now be known as SCP-001.
Then to make dozens of other randomly generated
entries and label them as SCP-001 as well.
He knows that they will need to keep the true
nature of what this entity can do a secret.
O5-3 walks out of the room.
Under his breath he speaks to himself, “they
said that I'll know the one true God when
I see it, and to give that God everything
it wants, because that's the only thing that
matters.
Tonight it appears God wants to talk to me.”
Calvin Lucien stands at the end of a dusty
table in an abandoned warehouse.
In the shadows across from him sit several
hidden figures.
The warehouse is falling apart, but is suitable
for the meeting Calvin has requested with
the heads of the Chaos Insurgency.
He has completed numerous missions for the
organization and each one has been successful;
now he is proposing one final mission.
Calvin Lucien takes a tattered journal out
of his bag and slides it across the table
to the figures sitting in the shadows.
“It’s a journal with details on the habits
of each of the thirteen Foundation Overseers,”
he says.
There is silence from the other end of the
table.
A hand reaches out and grabs the journal;
the pages begin to turn.
“The new models indicate an anomalous catastrophe
is imminent, not even the Foundation can stop
it.
The only way to save the world is to kill
the Overseers,” There are whispers from
across the table as Calvin continues.
“The proliferation of anomalies in the world
are the fault of the Overseers.
They have been meddling with reality, if business
continues as usual we might not make it out
of the 2020s.
We need to act now.”
The whispering from the shadows resumes, this
time with what seems to be a little more urgency.
One of the voices asks the question on everyone’s
mind, “How do you plan to kill the Overseers?
They have a deal with death, they are immortal.”
Calvin smiles and takes out a small vial from
his jacket pocket.
“With this,” he says.
There is silence from the shadows.The journal
slides back across the table and comes to
a stop right in front of Calvin.
A deep voice from the shadows says, “do
it.”
Calvin Lucien gathers his team; the codename
given to the group is “Killsquad.”
He informs them they have been cleared to
take out the Overseers.
It will be the most dangerous mission they’ve
ever been on, and even if successful, they
probably won't make it out alive.
But, the team is loyal, they set out to confront
the Thirteenth Overseer.
This has to be their first stop because without
eliminating O5-13, nothing else will matter.
It is this Overseer who has a deal with Death;
a deal that protects all of the Foundation
Overseers from dying.
If that deal can be broken, and O5-13 can
be eliminated, then Calvin Lucien and his
team will have a shot at eradicating the other
Overseers.
If the deal with Death cannot be broken, all
is lost.
The team boards a ship at the tip of South
America and sails towards the frozen waters
of Antarctica.
The Killsquad is made up of Calvin and three
others.
They sit in the galley preparing for the mission
ahead.
Anthony Wright is a battle hardened soldier
who sits at one end of the table.
His face is covered with scars.
No one can remember when he first joined the
Insurgency because it was so long ago.
Next to him is Olivia Torres.
She is an anarchist who was recruited into
the Insurgency after she was liberated from
a Foundation site during a raid.
Adam Ivanov sits staring into his computer
screen, he is testing different gadgets that
might be of use on the mission.
He pushes his glasses up the bridge of his
nose and strikes the “enter” key.
A long line of code begins to scroll across
the screen.
A siren begins to sound, informing the crew
to make their way to the main deck.
When they surface from the bowels of the ship
they see something in the distance.
It is a giant black tower rising from the
depths of the ocean like an evil iceberg.
Waves crash over the side of the railings,
drenching the deck and crew with frigid water.
Calvin looks at the jagged rocks along the
shore of the tower.
There is no way to safely dock; there is only
one way onto the island.
They know what needs to be done.
Anthony waits for the next wave, then opens
the throttle to full.
The ship is carried toward the island on the
crest of the wave.
The hull is impaled on the rocks surrounding
the tower sending everything flying towards
the front of the boat.
“See, that wasn’t so bad,” Calvin says
to his team as he bandages a gash on his head.
Knowing what lays ahead Calvin orders his
team to wait on the ship while he makes his
own deal with death.
He enters the dark structure and is greeted
by a corpse.
The corpse speaks to him, ejecting dust from
its lungs with every word; its breath smells
like decaying flesh.
Death has inhabited the body of Dr. Felix
Carter, the Thirteenth Overseer.
Calvin is prepared though thanks to the notes
in the journal he possesses.
Without hesitating, he takes out a small bottle
of liquid from his pocket and lunges at the
corpse.
He grabs it by the neck, tilts the head back,
and pours liquid down what is left of the
throat of Felix Carter.
The corpse reanimates into the living Dr.
Carter.
Death has been removed from his body by liquid
from the Fountain of Youth that Calvin had
acquired on a previous raid on a Foundation
site.
Seeing that Dr. Carter is now alive, Calvin
takes out his pistol and shoots the doctor
twice, killing him.
Calvin picks up the body and throws it into
a bottomless pit at the base of the tower.
Dr. Felix Carter’s body disappears from
sight.
The Overseers’ deal with death is now broken.
They are vulnerable and can be killed at last.
Calvin smiles and begins to turn away from
the pit when he comes face to face with Death.
She stands with her head cocked to the side
looking at Calvin.
“So it is you who has broken the Overseers’
deal with me, Calvin Lucien.”
Calvin takes a step back.
Why didn’t she stop him from killing Felix
Carter?
“Something festers at the heart of the council,”
Death says.
“Something that will not die.
I thought that, perhaps, if I had a seat at
their table, I could find it, make it die.
But I couldn’t.
There are things in this world beyond even
my reach, Calvin Lucien.”
With that parting thought Death vanishes.
The Killsquad contacts the Insurgency for
an evac and then makes their way to Japan
where O5-12, also known as The Accountant,
has been working out of Tokyo.
He is so proficient in mathematics and probability
that he can actually predict the future.
Everything about the Accountant’s life,
down to the number of breaths and steps he
takes each day, is predetermined based on
his own statistical models.
This poses a problem for Calvin and his team.
If The Accountant can see them coming, then
how can they possibly kill him?
That night The Accountant steps out of his
car.
He looks to the left and spots Adam.
He has already predicted this man has hostile
intentions.
The Accountant walks directly towards Adam,
and before he can react, throws the Killsquad
member to the ground.
Then he turns slightly and adjusts his watch
sending a glare directly into the window where
Anthony has the Accountant in the sights of
his sniper rifle.
Anthony fires, but misses, due to being blinded
by the glare.
The Accountant is surprised that he just barely
had time to avoid being shot, normally he
would be several steps ahead of anyone trying
to kill him.
He turns his head and watches as Olivia helps
Adam up and they run down a nearby alley.
The Accountant pursues them and corners the
Killsquad members in the alley.
He pulls a gun to shoot Adam, but Olivia tackles
Adam behind a dumpster as the bullet hits
the wall directly behind where Adam was standing.
The Accountant can’t believe that he missed,
and that he was almost tricked into being
captured by the Insurgency team.
He senses uncertainty in his assailants actions
and runs away unable to predict exactly what
they are planning to do.
The Accountant climbs the stairs to a subway
station and boards the last car of the train.
It is empty except for one man, Calvin Lucien.
The Accountant is dumbfounded.
“How are you here?” he screams.
“I should have seen this coming!”
Calvin stands up.
He uses his thumb to flip a coin into the
air.
On the way down he grabs it and smacks it
on the back of his opposing hand.
Calvin smiles.
The team has been making their decisions based
on the flip of a coin which introduced randomness
into their actions that even this super advanced
mathematician could not account for.
“Tell me where O5-11 is,” demands Calvin.
The Accountant pauses, then shakes his head
no.
If he’s going to die either way, then why
give any information to the Killsquad.
Calvin flips the coin up in the air, catches
it, and looks at it.
The coin is face up.
Calvin lifts his pistol and shoots The Accountant
in the head.
A few nights later Olivia stands on a balcony
outside of an art exhibit overlooking the
city of Seattle.
Anthony walks up behind her and tells her
that the Foundation is defeated but Olivia
doesn’t understand how.
“We broke the Overseers deal with death
and killed The Accountant, there is nothing
more to do.
We can go back to our normal lives” he tells
her.
Olivia is skeptical though.
What about the Eleventh Overseer?
And his ability to…
Olivia’s eyes suddenly open wide.
She pulls out a knife and stabs it into Anthony’s
heart.
The world around her begins to distort and
falls apart.
It was a false reality created by O5-11, better
known as The Liar.
Olivia wakes up next to Adam in a hotel room.
She sits up in bed and rubs her eyes.
What a weird dream, she thinks.
Then she realizes it wasn’t a dream.
She shakes Adam awake.
Neither of them have any idea how they ended
up here, but they know it must be the doing
of The Liar. they had planned for this though,
with Calvin having created a contingency plan.
They pull out a laptop log in to view the
classified information Calvin left for them.
Olivia begins to type but stops halfway through
her password and looks up from the screen.
Olivia pulls out the gun that rests under
her pillow and shoots Adam.
The false reality created by The Liar falls
apart around her.
Olivia comes out of the previous lie and is
sitting across a table from Calvin.
She immediately draws her pistol and points
it at Calvin's head.
Is it really him?
Or just another one of the Liar’s games?
Calvin tries to talk Olivia down as she looks
around the room for inconsistencies that might
tip her off that this is another lie, but
doesn’t find any.
Olivia begins to relax.
She tells Calvin that The Liar is trying to
get something from her.
Maybe the Journal can tell them what he is
looking for, as long as she still has it.
Olivia nods her head and holds out her wrist
where a subdermal chip with a copy of the
Journal on it has been placed.
Calvin looks at her wrist; the world around
them begins to dissipate as Calvin morphs
into the Liar.
Olivia wakes up in a hospital where she is
hooked up to an IV.
Sitting across from her is a former Insurgency
agent named Sam Biel.
He explains to her that he is The Liar.
He was forced into becoming a monster by the
Foundation.
They had manipulated him, but now he’s tired
of running and can’t do it anymore.
She is free to go.
Olivia hesitantly unhooks herself from the
IV.
She walks out of the hospital room and proceeds
down a fluorescent lit hallway.
As she walks away, she hears a gunshot from
the hospital room.
As Olivia is in the hospital, Calvin and Adam
walk through a dense forest.
They are searching for O5-10.
The Journal indicates that the Tenth Overseer’s
identity within the Foundation is The Archivist.
Calvin and Adam come upon a small clearing.
In the middle of the clearing are two saplings
standing side by side.
The void between the saplings shimmers.
Calvin walks through the portal, and space
begins to warp and twist around him.
His vision finally comes back into focus and
Calvin finds himself in another world.
Adam enters the world behind Calvin, practically
knocking him over as he enters through the
portal.
This is the Wanderer’s Library.
But it doesn’t look anything like they expected.
Instead of rows of books, the Library is filled
with computer mainframes, humming with the
collected knowledge of how to contain anomalies,
a critical backup.
As the two look intently at the strange machines,
a figure in a silver robe suddenly steps out
of the darkness.
It’s tall and thin, and though it’s hood
is pulled down so that they can’t see its
face, they can see that it’s hands are covered
in scales that have a slight, emerald tint.
It is one of the Librarians.
Calvin tells the Librarian that they are seeking
the Archivist, but the Librarian tells them
that the Archivist is no longer in the library.
She has broken her pact with the Serpent,
and eaten fruit from the forbidden trees.
If they want to see her though, the Librarian
can take them to her.
Calvin and Adam follow the Librarian down
a long staircase, passing by countless doors
filled with books, scrolls, works of art,
an entire universe of knowledge.
Eventually they reach the bottom of the stairs
where there stands a giant set of brass doors.
Beyond the door, the librarian explains, is
the source of all knowledge.
Before Calvin and Adam pass through the doors
though, Calvin turns to the Librarian.
“Before we go in, I’d like to make a withdrawal”
he says.
The librarian nods, and pulls a silver tube
out of its robe.
It hands the tube to Adam and he looks it
over in his hands.
He looks up to ask what this is, but the Librarian
has vanished.
The doors then open and the two step through.
Calvin and Adam feel as if they walk through
the same kind of portal that brought them
to the library, and find that they have walked
into a lush green valley with two trees.
Sitting underneath one of them is a woman
in a white dress.
She is reading a book and eating a piece of
fruit.
“Are you the Archivist?”
Calvin asks.
The woman nods yes and that’s all the confirmation
Calvin needs.
He raises his pistol and fires,, but the bullet
passes right through The Archivist as if she
wasn’t there.
“Do you read?” the Archivist asks Calvin,
seemingly not phased by his attempts to shoot
her.
“I haven’t had much time recently” Calvin
replied.
The Archivist explains that she’s read every
book in the library.
The collected knowledge of the universe is
in the books, even one on how to allow bullets
to pass through your body.
She came here to find the secret to immortality.
It’s her job to document everything that
happens in the world, and she can’t do that
if she’s dead.
She explains that she figured out that the
fruit that the Serpent forbade everyone to
eat wasn’t actual fruit, but the knowledge
contained in the library.
By having read every book, she had consumed
the fruit.
She no longer needed the Serpent, because
she was the Serpent.
The Archivist falls to the ground and begins
to writhe around, contorting her body as it
starts to change.
She begins to elongate as her limbs seemingly
disappear.
The next thing Calvin and Adam know, they
are face to face with a giant snake.
Calvin dodges as the serpent lunges at him
as Adam stands in the doorway firing at the
snake with his pistol, but just like with
the Archivist’s human form, the bullets
have no effect.
The Serpent coils itself around Calvin and
begins to choke the life from him as Adam
can only watch, helpless.
Calvin cries out with his last breath “The
tube, Adam!
Open the tube!”
Adam takes the tube that was given to him
by the Librarian and opens the cap.
A long, heavy spear slides out that looks
much too large to have ever fit inside.
He drops the tube to the ground and watches
in amazement as it starts to transform, turning
into what looks like a large harpoon gun.
Adam knows what to do and places the giant
spear into the gun and points it at the Serpent.
“You can’t kill me” the giant snake
says, “I’ve eaten from the tree of life!”
Adam pulls the trigger and the huge spear
flies through the air, striking the serpent
in the head.
Adam runs to Calvin and helps him to his feet.
They turn to look at the snake, but instead
of the menacing creature, it’s the Archivist
once again, pinned against the tree she once
sat under, the spear sticking out of her skull.
As the two stand, looking at the Archivist,
a tall, hooded, humanoid figure steps out
from behind the tree.
It looks similar to the Librarian except its
robe is a greenish color and it wears long
black gloves.
The creature pulls the spear out of the Archivist,
whose body slumps to the ground, and hands
the spear to Calvin.
“Who are you?”
Calvin asks, but his question is ignored.
After a moment, the figure finally speaks.
“That spear you now hold is called the Spear
of the Non-Believer, it is an ancient weapon
used to kill gods.
It is odd that someone in this realm gave
you the spear.
Even with it, I am not sure you will be able
to complete your quest Calvin Lucien, but
we shall see.”
There is a sudden flash of light and Calvin
and Adam find themselves transported back
to the forest they had entered The Wanderer’s
Library from.
A week later Calvin and Anthony track down
O5-9, who in the council, is known as The
Outsider.
She isn’t hard to find and it seems as if
she actually wanted to be found.
They find her sitting outside of her burnt
down family home.
The journal had listed this as her address,
but Calvin doubted that she would be here.
At most he hoped to find a clue to her whereabouts,
but here she was, sitting in the ashes of
her home.
Without turning around The Outsider began
speaking.
“The council just used me you know,” she
says.
“They took away my academic career, my friends,
and my life.
They made me conduct research for them that
compromised everything I stood for, and now
here I am, with nothing.”
The Outsider lets out a sigh.
She asks Calvin if he’s afraid of death.
Calvin shakes his head and responds, “no.”
The Outsider slumps forward and Calvin walks
around to face her.
She is covered in blood.
Her eyes move to look up at Calvin.
“You’re lying,” she says as she dies
from self inflicted wounds.
Calvin and Anthony cross O5-9 off of the list
and head back to the car.
As they walk, Anthony says what’s been on
everyones’ mind the last few days.
“The easy part is done.
It will only get harder from here.
We know O5-8 is in his castle, and I’m sure
we can get in, but I’m not sure we’ll
make it out alive.”
“I know,” replies Calvin.
“But if we are going to save the world,
we must eliminate the rest of the Overseers,
even if it means sacrificing our own lives.”
They get in the car and drive off into the
blood red sunset to pick up the rest of the
Killsquad team before their next mission.
Calvin Lucien leads the Killsquad team through
mud and freezing rain.
In front of them looms the fortress of Baron
Leeman Hoadley, the Eighth Overseer.
The team has already been through a lot: from
breaking the Overseer Council’s deal with
death by eliminating O5-13, to using the Spear
of the Non-Believer to kill the god like Archivist,
O5-10.
The hunting of Overseers has taken a toll
on the Killsquad.
O5-12 almost killed Adam, and Olivia was stuck
in what seemed like an endless mind game with
O5-11.
The first five Overseers were eliminated,
but the words that the Ninth Overseer spoke
to Calvin Lucien before she died still run
through his mind: are you afraid of death?
Now the Killsquad is about to infiltrate one
of the most heavily guarded facilities in
the world to eliminate the Eighth Overseer.
Upon reaching the castle the team is surprised
to find the structure in ruin.
No one is supposed to know the location of
O5-8 though.
The fortress was supposed to be practically
impregnable.
They storm the castle of O5-8 all the same.
The journal Calvin possesses that contains
information about the members of the SCP Foundation’s
powerful O5 Council identifies him as a former
industrialist named Baron Leeman Hoadley.
With his vast wealth, Hoadley funded the Foundation
at the start and was considered the unofficial
leader of the council in its early days with
immense control over the actions of the organization.
The Killsquad makes their way through the
dimly lit hallways of the castle.
As they turn the corner they are surprised
to find the charred remains of Baron Leeman
Hoadley’s bodyguards.
It seems that someone or something has gotten
to Hoadley before they could.
The team makes their way to the main chamber
and breaches the door.
Laying by a still lit fireplace is O5-8.
The Killsquad scan the room to make sure the
killer isn’t still in there with them.
Adam walks over to the body and examines it.
He quickly realizes that Hoadley hasn’t
been murdered at all.
He sees that Barron Hoadley’s body has been
drastically modified using anomalous technology.
The Overseer used his immortality to modify
almost every part of his body to make himself
stronger.
Unfortunately for Baron Hoadley, when the
Overseers’ deal with death was broken by
Calvin, the modifications to his body slowly
tore him apart.
His regular body could no longer support all
of the modifications, and what once made him
practically invincible became the very thing
that destroyed him.
The team leaves the castle and crosses O5-8
off of their list.
On their way out Adam pulls Calvin aside.
He has the feeling that Anthony hasn’t been
completely honest with the rest of the team.
He had the feeling that Antony was hiding
something from them.
Calvin had had similar thoughts recently.
He pushes Anthony for more information about
his past and Anthony reveals that he’s over
one hundred years old.
The vial of water from the Fountain of Youth
that Calvin has was not the only one.
Early in his career with the Insurgency he
had confiscated other vials from a Foundation
site.
His squad drank the water and it extended
their lives.
He asks Calvin what he plans on doing with
his water from the fountain.
“I’m going to destroy it,” Calvin tells
him.
Anthony agrees with this plan.
Once you drink from the fountain of youth
you may extend your life, but a part of you
dies at the same time.
“Vibrancy of the senses disappears, leading
to a seemingly shallow life.”
If Anthony could go back and do it again,
he never would have drank the water.
Calvin receives intel from the Insurgency
that the Seventh Overseer is in a small town
in Cambodia.
The Killsquad makes their way to the village
and surveys the area, hoping to get a glimpse
at the Overseer who is code named Green.
As the team conducts reconsiance, Anthony
tells them he thinks this mission is a setup.
It is too remote, and there are so many unknown
variables.
But, Calvin is convinced that this might be
their only chance to kill Green.
Since Green arrived in the area there has
been nonstop chaos.
She has destabilized the local governments
and now the area is in all out war.
The team weaves through narrow passageways
between houses and buildings, trying to make
their way to the central compound where Green
is located.
Suddenly a mob starts to form.
They are getting closer and closer to the
team.
In a quick decision to avoid being seen, Calvin
orders everyone into a nearby building.
Before Anthony can follow, the mob rounds
the corner.
They spot Anthony and he’s forced to flee.
Calvin, Olivia, and Adam watch as the mob
chases after Anthony, but they have to keep
moving.
Calvin knows that Anthony can take care of
himself, and they are too close to their goal
to stop now.
Calvin slowly opens the front door of the
house they are hiding in and peers out.
The coast looks clear, so he signals Olivia
and Adam to follow him.
Before they can step out into the street,
a gas canister enters through the cracked
doorway.
The room fills with sleeping gas and the team
passes out.
When they awake, they are tied up in a large
room with marble vaulted ceilings.
O5-7 is standing in front of Calvin.
She smiles wickedly while holding a knife.
She compliments Calvin on what he and his
team have been able to do so far.
No one believed they could pull off even a
fraction of what they have.
But now she has an offer for Calvin.
She points towards Adam and Olivia and tells
Calvin he must choose one of them to die.
If he doesn’t, she’ll kill the leader
of the rioters and plunge another part of
the country into chaos.
“Screw you” is Calvin’s response.
“Very well,” utters Green.
“Have it your way.”
She assassinates the leader being held in
her compound, then turns back to Calvin.
She now threatens to torture his team until
Calvin makes a choice of who to kill.
Green slashes Adam’s cheek with her knife
as Calvin screams for Green to leave his team
alone and torture him instead.
Green just smiles.
“I am going to enjoy killing your friends
while you watch, as you have killed so many
of my Overseers on the council.”
She reaches up in the air with the knife above
Adam’s head.
Before she can plunge the knife through his
skull a bullet passes through her hand, causing
her to drop the knife.
Anthony kneels on a rooftop across the courtyard,
smoking sniper rifle still pointed at Green
who runs.
Calvin uses the dropped knife to cut his ropes
and chases after Green.
He follows her to the roof where he watches
as she boards a helicopter.
The aircraft lifts off as Anthony fires at
it from his original position, but does no
serious damage.
In the plaza below the mob that had separated
the team earlier becomes restless.
There is complete chaos and someone fires
a rocket at the fleeing helicopter.
The rocket hits the tail of the aircraft,
sending it crashing into the plaza full of
rioters below as the crowd flees from the
scene.
Calvin makes his way towards the wreckage
and reaches the wreckage at the same time
Anthony does.
Calvin looks at him, smiles, and thanks him
for saving his life.
Anthony smiles back but before he can say
anything, a gunshot rings out and a bullet
rips through his neck.
Calvin turns to see where it came from and
is horrified to see the burning body of O5-8.
Her skin has been charred black, but in her
burnt hand she holds a gun.
What’s left of her lips curl back in a sinister
grin as she fires again and hits Anthony in
the chest.
He falls to the ground.
Calvin runs to him and pulls his gun out to
shoot O5-8, but she is already dead.
Calvin holds his dying teammate as blood pours
out of his neck and chest.
But Calvin can stop this.
He pulls out the vial of water from the Fountain
of Youth.
“No,” winces Anthony.
“I have lived long enough.
Thank you my friend, I will see you in whatever
lies beyond this life.”
Anthony’s chest rises then falls, it does
not rise again.
Olivia and Adam round the corner to see Calvin
holding the lifeless body of their teammate,
tears flowing from his eyes.
The team holds a small ceremony and burial
for Anthony, but they are only halfway through
their mission, and can’t stop now.
They fly back to the United States where an
undercover Insurgency agent named Kowalski
informs them that O5-6 is already aware they
are after him.
This Overseer is code named The American because
he has the power of the entire U.S. Military
at his fingertips.
The Killsquad scouts the base where The American
is located.
Kowalski warns them of a crate that was recently
brought to the base from Site-19.
The American showed great interest in whatever
was in the container.
The group sets up a camp on a hill overlooking
the base.
As the sun slowly rises the next day, the
Killsquad is spotted by a drone and forced
to hop in their Jeep and try to run.
They make their way down the hill, finding
themselves in the valley below with no clear
exit.
In front of them lands a helicopter as humvees
roar into the canyon behind them.
The team is surrounded.
A Jeep pulls up and O5-6 steps out.
He introduces himself as Rufus King, member
of the Overseer Council, but an American citizen
first and foremost.
All he really wants is to protect the country
he loves.
“Thanks to you, I have lost my immortality
and can no longer effectively protect the
United States anymore,” the American says
to Calvin.
“But I am willing to make a deal… your
freedom for the Spear of the Non-Believer.
Rumor has it that you have the spear in your
possession, and you used it to kill the Archivist.
If you give me the spear I will let you go.”
“No,” replies Calvin.
“I will never give an Overseer the means
to cause more destruction.
The spear stays with us.”
“Very well,” the American says with a
frown.
“Then I suppose my only other option is
to take it from you, but not without giving
you a fair chance.
Run Calvin Lucien.
Run as fast as you can, I will be coming for
you.”
The American turns and walks towards the container
from Site-19, which is being lowered from
a helicopter hovering above them.
Calvin sprints back to the Jeep with the other
members of his team.
As they drive away they hear a horrible, guttural,
screech from whatever was inside the container.
After a few moments the army begins to pursue
them, out in front of the military force is
O5-6 riding SCP-682.
He is using a black whip to urge the creature
forward, and they’re gaining on the Killsquad…
fast.
A row of vehicles pulls up beside The American
and SCP-682, then something strange happens.
A man appears in front of the oncoming forces
led by the American.
The man’s skin bulges and seems to be moving
from within.
The skin of the man sloughs from his body.
The infection that is SCP-610 erupts out of
him and onto the soldiers in a nearby Jeep.
SCP-610 begins to infect and consume everyone
around it.
Suddenly, there are thousands of instances
of SCP-610 coming from the mountain side,
flooding into the valley.
They close in around the army and O5-6.
The American begins fighting off the flesh
eating creatures from the back of SCP-682,
but he becomes overwhelmed.
He can no longer focus on pursuing Calvin
and his team.
From the back of the Jeep Olivia pulls out
her rifle.
She aims and fires.
The bullet hits The American in the chest.
He is flung off the back of SCP-682 and engulfed
in a sea of SCP-610 creatures.
The Killsquad continues to drive, trying to
put as much distance between themselves and
the SCP-610 infestation as possible.
But then Calvin suddenly slams on the breaks.
Standing in front of them is a man in a black
suit and bow tie.
He introduces himself as Blackbird, the Fifth
Overseer.
According to the journal his actual name is
Mortimer J. Denning Von Kronecker.
He stands in front of the Jeep with a menacing
grin.
“You have been causing a lot of trouble,”
he says looking at Calvin.
Olivia swings her gun around.
“Please my dear, that won’t help you,”
Von Kronecker says.
He pulls out a knife and stabs himself through
the neck.
He falls to the ground apparently dead.
There is a gust of wind, a whiff of ozone,
and an identical copy, and still very much
alive, Von Kronecker lands next to his own
dead body.
“See what I mean,” he says.
Olivia lowers her rifle.
“Come with me; I have something to show
you,” the Blackbird beccons.
Seeing no other option Calvin, Olivia, and
Adam exit the Jeep and follow the Blackbird.
As they walk, the world changes around them.
The desert mountains fade away into blackness
and they find themselves in a near-apocalyptic
London.
“Ah, it’s good to be home,” the Blackbird
says as they emerge onto a cobblestone street.
“You cannot stop the Overseers plans, however,
I can give you an alternative.
Let’s see if any of you will take it.”
In front of each Killsquad member appears
a door.
They have an uncontrollable urge to open their
respective door and walk through.
The Blackbird stands smiling as he watches
Calvin, Olivia, and Adam enter each of their
portals.
Adam enters his door and looks around.
He is in Portland.
His parents walk into the room.
In this universe his family has been granted
asylum.
Adam never has to interact with any SCPs or
the Foundation.
He is free to live a normal life.
From the kitchen comes Calvin wearing an apron.
He is holding a steaming pot.
Adam locks eyes with Calvin who smiles at
him.
The Blackbird whispers into Adam’s ear,
“in this reality both of your parents and
siblings are still alive.
Also, the man you love loves you back, you
and Calvin could be married if you stayed
here, wouldn’t that be nice?”
Olivia enters her door.
She is on the deck of a yacht.
At the bow sits an easel with art supplies.
The man that Olivia once loved walks across
the deck towards her.
The Blackbird looms over her, “in this reality
you didn’t accidentally kill him.
This could be your happily ever after.
Wouldn’t that be nice?”
Calvin steps through his door.
He is in a grassy clearing near a lake.
The Blackbird hisses in Calvin’s ear, “I’m
giving you the opportunity to save your mother
this time Calvin.
You were just a scared little boy, but in
this reality you can be brave.
You can actually save your mother from her
fate.”
“No!”
Calvin screams.
“This isn’t real!”
The Blackbird cackles.
Calvin looks away from the lake and towards
the treeline.
Hidden in the shadows he can just barely make
out a hooded figure.
Calvin walks towards it.
The Blackbird follows, he is screaming at
the person in the treeline.
“I was only trying to help!”
The hooded figure reaches out and hands Calvin
a metal tube.
He opens it to find a set of eyeglasses inside.
Calvin puts them on and turns to look at the
Blackbird.
He steps back in horror.
The glasses have revealed the true form of
the Blackbird.
He is a winged, pseudo-avian, monstrosity
full of rage.
The mysterious hooded figure directs Calvin
to open the tube again.
Inside is an interdimensional fishing line
made by Dr. Wondertainment, and white wiffle
ball bat.
Calvin grabs the fishing line and wraps it
around O5-5’s leg.
The Blackbird flies into the air trying to
get away from Calvin, but Calvin wraps the
other end of the fishing line around his arm.
The Blackbird begins to jump from dimension
to dimension trying to get rid of Calvin.
They appear on the deck of SCP-455, in Site-19
where SCP-682 walks freely, in the dead world
of SCP-2935.
Every time they stop in a new dimension, Calvin
takes the opportunity to attack the Blackbird
with the bat.
And it seems that he is slowly weakening the
monster.
They finally land at the bottom of a Deepwell
Foundation containment site, where the Darkbody
that is SCP-001 is contained.
Standing in front of the containment field
is Alison Chao, The Black Queen, whose sole
mission is to destroy the Foundation.
“You!” cries the Blackbird.
“You are the one who has been helping Lucien!”
The Black Queen nods her head.
“Yes, I have been helping Calvin Lucien
to eliminate you and the other Overseers.
The Foundation must fall.”
“You are nothing!
You cannot stop me!
I am The Black King!” screams O5-5.
Alison Chao sighs.
She pushes a button on the panel next to her,
shutting down the array containing the Darkbody.
Out of the cloud of dust appears SCP-001,
a massive black creature who seemed to absorb
all light.
“No!
Stop!” shrieks the Blackbird.
SCP-001 does not move, but the room begins
to shake.
The Blackbird continues to scream as his body
folds in on itself until he is reduced to
a single superheated point, and then blinks
out of existence.
Alison Chao then reactivates the containment
array, sealing 001 away once again.
“I will return you to your reality along
with your friends,” says the Black Queen.
“But perhaps our paths shall cross again
Calvin Lucien.”
There is a bright flash of light and Calvin
finds himself on a private jet sitting next
to Olivia and Adam.
They are all shaken, but the Blackbird is
dead.
O5-5 has been eliminated.
The three members of the team sit silently,
still pondering what might have been if they
stayed in the alternate realities.
Suddenly, the phone on the plane begins to
ring, breaking the silence.
Calvin picks it up.
On the other line is the Fourth Overseer.
He has contacted Calvin to discuss surrendering
to the Insurgency.
Unfortunately, things do not always go as
planned.
Calvin Lucien is about to make the most difficult
and dangerous decision of his life.
Aaron Siegel, better known to Foundation members
as O5-1, descends into the abyss of a Deepwell
site.
He exits the elevator and peers into the optical
scanner to unlock the reinforced door.
Inside the room is Mobile Task Force Tau-5…
Samsara.
Aaron Siegel refers to these immortal cyborg
clones, created from the flesh of a dead god,
as his Red Right Hand.
“Your mission is to eliminate the traitor
O5-4, and to find the insurgents who have
been killing the members of the Overseer Council.”
The cyborgs stand at attention.
“Now!”
Aaron Siegel screams.
The soldiers of the Red Right Hand march out
the door to start their mission.
Aaron Siegel pauses for a moment and then
slams his fist against the wall in frustration.
He has lost nine Overseers to Calvin Lucien
and his Kill Squad team.
They have been somehow overcoming the odds
each time, and eliminating each Overseer they
track down.
It wasn’t supposed to end this way.
Aaron Siegel vows to kill them all.
Calvin Lucien, meanwhile, sits on a private
jet with Adam and Olivia.
He had just hung up the phone after a conversation
with O5-4.
The Overseer known as the Ambassador wants
to surrender to the Insurgency.
There’s a good chance this is a trap, but
Calvin has decided to meet with the Ambassador
all the same.
Calvin drops off Adam and Olivia at an Insurgency
base.
They still haven’t fully recovered from
the previous mission with O5-5, known as the
Blackbird.
Before leaving though, Calvin meets with an
Insurgency agent named Sylvester Sloan, who
is going to join him as support.
Calvin says goodbye to Adam and Olivia, then
leaves with Sloan to meet The Ambassador in
South Africa.
After landing at Johannesburg airport, Calvin
and Sloan disembark and are led to a conference
room where the Ambassador sits waiting for
them.
Calvin and Sloan sit across from O5-4 to discuss
his surrender.
“The Council is in shambles,” says The
Ambassador, “everything is falling apart.
I want to offer my services and information
to the Insurgency in exchange for protection
from O5-1.
He has lost his mind.”
Calvin agrees to the terms and prepares for
extraction.
But as they get up from the table gunshots
can be heard from down the hall.
The Ambassador’s eyes open wide in terror.
“It’s too late,” he whispers.
Calvin and Sloan grab the Ambassador, who
is frozen in fear, and exit the conference
room.
They make their way toward their plane, but
the gun shots are getting closer.
Calvin looks over his shoulder to see Samsara
pursuing them through the terminal.
Calvin shoves the Ambassador behind a table
as bullets whiz overhead.
Calvin and Sloan return fire, but their volly
doesn’t seem to slow down the assassins.
Calvin and Sloan pull the Ambassador to his
feet and they burst through an emergency exit
onto the sun baked tarmac where they make
a mad dash for the plane.
From behind them a bullet rips through the
chest of Sloan.
The Red Right Hand has caught up, but Calvin
continues to drag the Ambassador towards the
plane.
They are almost there.
Suddenly, a metallic child’s voice blares
through the airport’s external speakers.
The child’s voice says, “I want Calvin
Lucien alive.
I have business to settle with him.”
The Red Right Hand soldiers tackle Calvin
and the Ambassador to the ground when they
are just feet away from the plane.
“Kill the traitor,” the child’s voice
says, and Calvin can only watch helplessly
as the Ambassador is violently murdered.
One of the agents turns towards Calvin and
slams his fist into Calvin's face causing
him to black out.
Calvin awakens in a dark room.
He is unsure how much time has passed.
The only light in the room comes from a screen
on the wall.
In the middle of the screen is a rotating,
red, SCP Foundation seal.
A voice from a speaker speaks.
“Hello Calvin Lucien, my name is The Kid.
I am the Third Overseer.
You have killed all of my friends... and now
I will kill all of yours.”
The door to the room opens.
Calvin leans through the doorway.
There is a long, dimly lit, hallway.
The Kid orders him to proceed, so that they
can meet face to face.
As Calvin walks, the Kid’s voice echoes
down the hallway.
“There once was another O5-3.
He built incredible machines, even one that
could see into the future.
But unfortunately for him, he did not have
the passion required to be an Overseer.
That was when I was… born.
I was chosen by the other Overseers to have
my spinal cord severed in a way that gave
me the ability of the All-Seeing Eye.
I now watch everything, all of the time.
I have perfect reasoning, perfect awareness,
and perfect understanding.”
Calvin gets to the end of the corridor, which
opens up into a large chamber.
Tied up in the middle of the room are Olivia
and Adam.
Calvin runs to his friends and crouches down
next to them.
A mechanical suit stands on a platform looking
down at Calvin, Olivia, and Adam.
Calvin realizes the Kid must be contained
inside.
“I now sentence you all to death,” the
mechanical suit says as the Red Right hand
steps out of the shadows and slowly walks
towards the remaining members of the Killsquad.
Suddenly, there is a flash of light and The
Black Queen appears.
“Stop!
What are you doing?” shrieks the Kid.
The Black Queen hands Calvin the interdimensional
rod and reel he used to defeat the Blackbird.
Calvin casts the rod.
From out of the tear in space comes a massive,
multi-armed creature, known as Malidramagiuan.
The Red Right Hand engages the monster trying
to force it back into its dimension.
But the monster is too powerful.
It grabs the cyborg clones and pulls them
through the tear in reality.
As Samsara battles the Malidramagiuan, Calvin
frees Olivia and Adam.
They make a run for the door, but as they
flee, one of the walls opens up to reveal
a turret.
The gun fires and a bullet hits Olivia directly
in the head, killing her instantly.
“No!” yells Calvin.
But before Calvin can push Adam out of the
way, a second bullet from the turret lodges
itself in Adam’s back.
Calvin and Adam slide across the floor.
The Kid in his mechanical suit jumps down
from the platform above.
“I am going to kill you now Calvin Lucien,”
he says in his mechanical voice.
There is another flash of light.
Calvin watches in front of him as the Spear
of the Non-Believer manifests itself before
his eyes.
Calvin grabs the spear and shoves it into
The Kid’s machine body.
It easily penetrates the armor and pins him
to the wall.
Calvin walks up to the exoskeleton and tears
off the outer plating, revealing a tank full
of fluid, within which floats a malformed
human fetus.
As Calvin finally looks upon the Kid’s true
form, he hears the sound of mocking mechanical
laughter.
Calvin breaks the glass and crushes The Kid
with his bare hands.
As Calvin turns from the now silent robotic
body of The Kid, the room begins to shake,
debris raining down from above.
Calvin helps Adam up and puts Olivia’s lifeless
body across his shoulders.
What remains of the Killsquad makes their
way out of The Kid’s lair.
Outside of the Foundation site where they
were being held, Calvin helps Adam to lie
down on the ground before gently setting Olivia’s
body next to him.
Adam grimaces as blood pours out of the wound
in his back.
Calvin reaches into his pocket and pulls out
the vial of water from the Fountain of Youth.
There are only a couple drops left, which
he pours into Adam’s mouth.
Adam looks up at Calvin, tears filling his
eyes, he whispers “I love you” before
he passes out from the pain.
The wound in his back begins to heal instantly
and Calvin calls an Insurgency evac team to
come pick up Adam.
With Adam safe, Calvin picks up Olivia and
walks alone towards a truck in the lot outside
of the Foundation site.
He needs to finish this once and for all.
He will kill the last two Overseers, or he
will die trying.
O5-1, Aaron Siegel arrives at where the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers meet.
The Garden of Eden.
He is in a frenzy due to the assassinations
of all the other Overseers besides himself
and The Nazarene and nothing will stop him.
As he approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though, he is stopped by the Guardian
of the Garden, a massive, powerful anomalous
entity with a flaming sword.
But Aaron Siegel has no time, or patience,
for anything to get in his way.
Even something as powerful as the Gate Guardian.
The Guardian swings his burning sword at Adam
who rolls out of the way and, in a flash,
takes out a Scranton Reality Anchor.
He slams the anchor into the ground which
causes the world to shimmer and ripple around
him.
He watches as the flames from the Gate Guardian’s
sword seem to absorb back into its body, before
it shrinks down, looking to fold in on itself
until all that is left is a charred skeleton.
With the Guardian defeated, Aaron sprints
into the Garden.
He searches the garden for O5-2, but can’t
find her anywhere.
He finally comes to the Tree of Life, and
that’s where he finds her.
Laying at the base of the tree in a pool of
blood is The Nazarene, she has taken her own
life.
This is her anomalous power though.
She has died many times before yet Death always
spared her and brought her back.
But somehow, he knows this time is final.
Aaron drops to his knees and screams in frustration.
For all the power Aaron Siegel possesses,
there’s nothing he can do now.
He sits next to The Nazarene’s body for
hours, hoping that she might wake up, or that
he will to find that this was all a dream.
After sitting next to her cold body for some
time, he notices something in her snowy white
hand.
It’s a note.
In it The Nazarene explains that she was the
one who gave the vials from the Fountain to
Calvin Lucien, and that she is the one who
made the spear appear before him that he used
to kill The Kid.
She explained that while she died many times
and Death always brought her back, each time
she felt less and less like herself, less
and less like Dr. Sophia Light.
She hoped that maybe if things ended up like
this, it would give Aaron the chance to walk
away and live the life that they might have
been able to have together, but she knows
deep down that Aaron’s fate is to meet Calvin
and finish things once and for all.
Aaron Siegl screams in rage, clutching the
note in his hand.
He tries to summon Death, but no one comes.
Aaron Siegel is alone.
He stands up and walks deeper into the Garden.
He walks until he reaches a spot where even
God’s light does not reach.
In this desolate land is an impact crater
where Lucifer, Star of the Morning, had fallen.
In the middle of the crater lies Lucifer’s
sword.
Aaron Siegel descends into the hole and picks
up the sword.
He turns and exits the Garden of Eden.
Aaron Siegel has only one mission in life
now… to kill Calvin Lucien.
Calvin reads the final entry of the journal.
In it the author warns that although he hopes
the information contained within the journal
is helpful, he hopes the reader does not try
to use it.
The words written on the final page are: “this
information will only lead you to a devastating
end.”
Calvin closes the journal and looks up at
the structure in front of him.
He has made it to Site-01.
He had left Olivia’s body in a cave nearby,
promising to her that he would make this right.
He now walks up to the massive doors and places
his hand on the knotted wood.
The doors slowly creek open.
Calvin pauses for a moment and looks behind
him at the setting sun, he enters Site-01,
where he knows O5-1 is.
Where Aaron Siegel waits.
Inside the main hall Calvin sees a giant doorway
in the shape of the SCP Foundation seal, with
artistic depictions of certain SCPs that he
instinctively knows are special in some way.
Standing next to the doorway is a 2 meter
tall man in what looks to be a futuristic
suit.
Calvin approaches and asks who this giant
man is, he responds that his name is Purpose,
the Red Right Hand.
He is the guardian of O5-1 and none shall
enter the sanctum until he returns.
“He isn’t here?” asks Calvin.
“No” Purpose responds, “he is.”
And with that he steps aside and lets Calvin
pass through the doorway.
The doorway leads into a large room where
screens on the wall flash to life, depicting
moments from Calvin’s journey, documenting
his entire quest.
Had he been in control at all?
Or was this all a setup to lead him to this
moment?
As he walks forward he finally sees him.
Sitting at a table in the middle of the room,
is Aaron Siegel.
“You are O5-1?”
Calvin asks.
“Aaron” the man responds.
“My name is Aaron.”
Calvin asks about the location of the second
Overseer, the Nazarene, but O5-1 doesn’t
respond.
Without needing any more information, Calvin
pulls out his sidearm and in a flash fires
off five shots.
The bullets stopped in the air, inches away
from Aaron, before dissolving in a flash of
light.
Calvin should have known it wouldn’t be
this easy.
“Stand up, Aaron Siegel” Calvin calls
out as he holsters his gun.
“Let’s finish it.”
Calvin pulled the spear of the non-believer
from his back but Aaron’s only response
was to laugh.
“You don’t even know why you’re here”
Aaron said.
Calvin calls back “I’m here to kill you,
because when I do, I kill the Foundation.
Because when you’re gone the universe can
finally heal.”
“You’re like me, Calvin Lucien.
We are both men driven by our own convictions,
regardless of the outcome.
It would seem fate has brought us together.
Now, either your convictions will be broken,
or you will die,” says Aaron Siegel.
He then draws Lucifer’s flaming sword and
lunges towards
As the two men clash with one another, their
supernatural weapons begin to destroy the
room around them.
Furniture is shattered, video screens are
obliterated, and fire spreads across the walls.
Aaron catches Calvin off balance and swings
the flaming sword across Calvin’s stomach.
Calvin slides back from the impact, hunching
over from the pain in his midsection.
He brings his head up to see Aaron Sigel running
towards him with the flaming sword high in
the air.
Calvin brings up the spear; from his knees
he leans back and launches it towards Aaron
Siegel.
The spear enters the final Overseer’s chest;
the force from the throw pinning him against
the wall.
Aaron Siegel drops Lucifer’s sword.
It shatters as it hits the ground.
He clutches the shaft of the spear protruding
from his sternum with both hands.
O5-1 looks at Calvin unbelievingly.
“You have no idea what you’ve done.
It was never about the Overseers,” Aaron
Siegel says, spitting out blood with every
word.
“It was something deeper - something worse.”
Calvin walks slowly towards Aaron Siegel.
He stops just in front of his final enemy.
“This is the way it ends,” Calvin says.
Aaron Siegel manages to whisper one final
word “Sophia…” before his body finally
goes limp.
Calvin turns to see Purpose standing behind
him.
“He’s dead” Calvin says, half to Purpose
and half to himself “I killed him.”
After a moment he asks Purpose what he really
wants to know.
“There’s a room in this facility where
someone could unmake the Foundation, right?
Take me there.”
Without any hesitation, Purpose leads Calvin
back to the room with depictions of important
SCPs.
There, Purpose opens the door to an elevator
but stops Calvin before he can get inside.
“I’m duty bound to tell you” Purpose
says, “that once you step inside this elevator,
there is no going back.
There is only one decision to be made and
it is not one that can be unmade.”
“I know,” Calvin responds.
“It’s time” before stepping inside.
The elevator doors open to reveal a room filled
with bookcases and a huge window offering
a beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains.
On the wall are more monitors depicting the
ways he had killed all of the Overseers, and
in the middle of the room is a large desk
with a computer.
Calvin sits down at the desk and the computer
comes to life.
The computer prompts him to scan his fingerprint,
which it accepts.
He’s logged in.
The computer screen displays numerous locations
around the planet, and he quickly recognizes
that they are all SCP Foundation sites.
Then he sees the single option the computer
is giving him.
“Terminate”
Calvin reaches out with his finger, this is
it, once he presses this button, the SCP Foundation
will be no more.
His finger is millimeters from the button
when -
The phone rings.
Calvin hadn’t even noticed that there was
a phone on the desk Calvin stares at it for
a moment then picks it up.
“Hello?” he says.
The voice on the other line responds.
“Hello Calvin Lucien, my name is The Administrator.
I have been following your work for some time
now, and I must say, I am impressed.
I have just been informed that you have completed
your mission, congratulations are in order.”
“What the hell are you talking about?”
Calvin asks.
“Please listen,” says the voice on the
other line.
“The man you just killed was once in the
same exact position you are in now.
Granted, it was a very long time ago, but
Aaron Siegel originally was trying to destroy
the Foundation; that was until I convinced
him otherwise.
And now, like Aaron Siegel, you will become
the new head of the Foundation.”
“Like hell I will!” yells Calvin.
“I could hang up, walk away right now, and
be done with all of this!”
“You could,” continues the Administrator,
“But if no one is in charge of the SCP Foundation,
millions of people will die, if not billions,
and then nobody would be there to manage what
comes after.”
There is silence from Calvin.
“That’s what I thought,” says the Administrator.
“I look forward to working with you Calvin
Lucien… or should I say O5-1.”
The line goes dead.
The Ouroboros Cycle.
One of the biggest, most legendary series
of entries in the history of the SCP Foundation.
We’ve covered the events of this SCP-001
epic in six videos - which, we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to avoid
your brain exploding from the sheer scope
of it all.
Because that’s the thing about the Ouroboros
Cycle - it’s a story so big, sprawling,
and dense that it can feel almost like an
anomaly itself.
Whether you’re immersed in the possible
origin of the Broken God, the sentient black
hole that can destroy whole universes, or
Calvin Lucien’s quest to assassinate the
O5 Council, it can sometimes be difficult
to see the forest of the trees.
But worry not, because that’s exactly why
we’re here today.
We’re going to step back and look at this
anomalous odyssey as a whole, and ask the
big question: Why is it all here together?
What makes these four different storylines
- The Children, The Broken God, Atonement,
and The Way It Ends - one big cycle?
As with anything involving the SCP Foundation,
there’s always going to be an element of
personal interpretation, but now that we’ve
gone through the whole cycle, we think it’s
worth adding our two cents to the proceedings.
So, let’s start broad.
A question you’ve probably been wondering
is, what do the words “Ouroboros Cycle”
actually mean?
And what is their significance to the four
stories within?
While the spelling can differ, Ouroboros refers
to the ancient symbol of a snake or dragon
eating its own tail, forming a circle - a
direct connection to the concept of “cycles.”
The Ouroboros symbol has existed in a huge
number of cultures, from the Ancient Egyptians
to the Ancient Greeks to modern Gnostic traditions.
It’s often used in alchemy or other magical
practices, and has a variety of meanings such
as eternal life, the endless cycle of death
and rebirth, and the cycle of renewal.
Anyone familiar with the tales within the
Ouroboros Cycle is probably already noticing
some similarities.
Cycles are a common theme in all of these
works.
People endlessly repeat mistakes, threats
thought to be contained or destroyed return,
and oftentimes, those who go out on a quest
to destroy something end up becoming what
they wished to destroy in the first place.
In a cycle, there is no true end and no true
beginning.
Everything repeats endlessly.
But let’s start at the closest thing to
a beginning we have: The Children.
In this tale, the Foundation faces off against
a terrifying, reality-warping group of interest
known as the Kingdom of Abaddon.
This nasty group which came from the Sahara
desert could seemingly take anything the Foundation
threw at them, and were able to straight-up
vaporize anyone who got too close.
If the Kingdom was able to amass enough power,
it could spell the end of the Foundation,
and even the subjugation of the human race.
Enter O5-1, a recurring character in the Ouroboros
Cycle.
This outside the box thinker put all his chips
on the Twins of God Project, designated SCP-001,
like many anomalies before and after it.
This project would infuse a human being with
godlike powers, but it was a power so great
that it seemed to kill anyone who attempted
to accept it.
Needless to say, this was a major bummer for
O5-1, but through relentless human experimentation
- even sacrificing the population of entire
towns to the project - he eventually came
up with a solution.
A horrifying solution, but a solution nonetheless.
He found that a group of nine children, with
ages varying from four to eleven, could act
as a human conduit for 001’s power - and
as a result, it could be the weapon capable
of turning the tide against the Kingdom of
Abaddon.
During the testing phase, though, it seemed
like O5-1 went a little mad with power.
He vaporized an entire Church of the Broken
God place of worship, and used the power of
The Children to wipe a few others off the
map at his own discretion.
His abuses of power got so flagrant that The
Administrator himself was called in to get
a handle on the situation.
And, surprise surprise, O5-1 disintegrated
him too, before disappearing himself shortly
afterwards.
In the end, The Children were deemed too dangerous
to be practical, both because of their anomalous
powers and from the level of ambient radiation
they put out.
All nine were locked in radiation-proof boxes
and buried in the desert, though they each
show signs of life to this day.
While this may seem disconnected from the
rest of the series, it actually establishes
some of the most important recurring themes
and ideas of the Cycle as a whole.
Namely, the Foundation messing with reality
and performing horrific acts to achieve their
goals, the corruption of the O5 Council, and
the fact that these grand attempts to change
or save the world often blow up in everyone’s
faces, sometimes literally.
We also have the introduction and apparent
death of the mysterious Administrator, but
trust us, all is not what it seems with this
one.
The ripple effect beginning here will affect
everything going forward.
Next, The Broken God.
This tells the chaotic story of a magical
clockwork box which is worshipped by the Church
of the Broken God as a conduit to their deity,
and eventually becomes an all-devouring, mechanical
kaiju.
The beast - soon dubbed SCP-001 - devoured
and consumed all the metal around it, slowly
becoming larger and more destructive.
If the Foundation didn’t take it out before
it reached critical mass, they’d be going
toe to toe with a bonafide God - a fight they
really weren’t sure they could win.
Thankfully, and with a little anomalous help
from SCP-2399, the Foundation was able to
destroy the anomaly.
They removed its clockwork heart from the
wreckage and contained the anomalous scrap
that once comprised its destructive body.
However, the Foundation soon realized that
you just can’t keep a good God down.
The clockwork heart eventually evaded Foundation
containment while being shipped to a secondary
location, and instead ended up in a small
town.
Here, it began to influence the minds of the
residents into more subservient Broken God
cultists, intent on building him back up to
his former glory.
It’d be easy to discount The Broken God
as an outlier, seeing as the Foundation came
out looking much better here than they do
in any of the other Ouroboros tales.
But when you look carefully, its place in
the overall Cycle is clear.
The entry ends the way it begins, with the
heart of the Broken God influencing humans
to carry out its bidding.
The Foundation had to intervene in between
these two instances, but in the end, there
was no net loss to the Broken God itself.
In a sense, the Foundation is doomed to encounter
the same problems again and again, continually
defending the world from the same anomalous
threats.
And the Foundation needs to succeed every
time to maintain peace and normality.
A major anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray.
In many ways, that is the curse of the SCP
Foundation.
Speaking of major anomalous threats, now it’s
time for part three of the Ouroboros Cycle:
Atonement.
Once again, we start off with the Foundation
meddling with cosmic-scale powers with the
creation of the Area-11 Pietrykau-Fontaine
Spatial Stabilization Array.
Try saying that three times fast!
This was a machine so powerful it was capable
of creating a singularity, though what it
actually ended up doing was turning Dr. Calvin
Desmet into an abomination.
More specifically, into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole, whose powers
were only restrained by the very machine that
created him.
Think of him as a kind of malicious Doctor
Manhattan from Watchmen.
This new entity, dubbed SCP-001, presented
a grim prophecy and an ominous offer.
He told the O5 Council that anomalies were
leaking into their universe from other realities,
and soon, the anomalous threat would destroy
them all.
His offer was to, upon his release, wipe out
the rest of the multiverse entirely, leaving
only our reality, free from anomalous threats.
Unsurprisingly, it was O5-1 that was most
interested in this offer - so much so that
he held a vote, and murdered everyone who
voted against the decision to release SCP-001.
Having built his consensus among the survivors
on the council, O5-1 let SCP-001 out.
Unsurprisingly, this turned out to be a terrible
decision, as one of his first acts upon being
freed was to kill the members of the O5 Council
that had just voted to release 001, saying
that they themselves were anomalous and needed
to be purged to atone for their past sins.
The only survivor was the member of the Council
who abstained from the vote, who was able
to recontain SCP-001 inside the Pietrykau-Fontaine
Array...for now.
Once again, the thematic connections to the
rest of the Ouroboros Cycle is clear.
We have a world-ending anomaly held off, but
only temporarily, buying time before the cycle
inevitably continues.
We have the Foundation abusing its power,
and signing off on the death of countless
people in other dimensions.
And of course, the O5 Council stepped out
of their bounds and actively warped reality,
just like they had with The Children before.
Their chickens truly come home to roost though
in the final part of the cycle.
Appropriately named The Way It Ends, this
piece chronicles the story of Calvin Lucien
and the Killsquad, an elite group of four
Chaos Insurgency soldiers with one goal: Assassinating
the entire O5 Council, thirteen of the most
powerful people in the world.
Why?
Because they’ve been messing with reality
itself time and time again, and it’s getting
to the point that their selfish meddling could
finally destroy everything.
And given that we’ve already seen it happen
with The Children and the entity that Dr.
Calvin Desmet became, it’s hard to disagree
with them.
What follows is one of the longest and most
complicated tales in all of the Foundation,
as the Killsquad systematically encounters
and kills each insane, anomalous member of
the O5 Council.
In order to do this, they need to make deals
with Death itself, fight giant serpents, cross
dimensions, deal with SCP-610 and SCP-682
containment breaches, and go toe to toe with
Samsara, arguably the Foundation’s deadliest
Mobile Task Force.
A number of other insane things happen along
the way, like O5-1 murdering the Gate Guardian
with a Scranton Reality Anchor, and the Black
Queen - the most prominent member of the Serpent’s
Hand - helping our heroes defeat more Overseers.
In the end, Calvin Lucien, despite losing
almost everything, reigns victorious in the
final battle.
Using The Spear of the Non-Believer, a weapon
so powerful it can kill Gods, Calvin managed
to finally kill the top member of the Overseers,
O5-1.
With the O5 Council destroyed, Calvin set
about completing his final task: Destroying
the entire SCP Foundation.
But that didn’t happen.
Instead, he was contacted by a mysterious
and immensely powerful being known as The
Administrator, who gave him some frightening
news: He’d just been hired by the SCP Foundation
to be their new O5-1.
This was where our last video on the Ouroboros
series left us.
What happens next, you may ask?
How does Calvin respond to this offer he seemingly
can’t refuse?
In this case, it seems that the Administrator,
a being so completely tied to the nature of
the Foundation itself, is SCP-001.
And while it seemed that the Overseers were
mad with power, they were actually always
there to keep the Administrator in check.
Aaron Siegler, the O5-1 that Calvin had just
killed, was doing the exact same thing Calvin
was doing when he became O5-1: Trying to destroy
the Foundation.
But the Foundation and the Administrator cannot
be beaten, they can only be joined.
And that’s exactly what Calvin did, becoming
the new O5-1, turning his back on the Chaos
Insurgency, and rebuilding the rest of the
council and the Foundation in his own image.
Insurgency members who were once his allies
vowed revenge for this betrayal, perhaps suggesting
that history would go on to repeat itself
once more in future.
Because, at the end of the day, that’s what
the Ouroboros Cycle really is - the recurring
threat and the changing of the guards that
accompanies it.
There will always be a Foundation, there will
always be an Administrator, there will always
be an O5 Council.
Nothing starts, nothing ends, all that ever
changes are the names and faces involved - whether
it’s Calvin Lucien or Aaron Siegler, the
wheel keeps turning, the snake devours its
own tail.
The Ouroboros Cycle is, and forever will be,
eternal.
Now go check out our full, piece by piece
breakdown on the Ouroboros cycle starting
with SCP-001 The Children, and then check
out “SCP-5000 Why?
- The Full Story Compilation”, just in case
we haven’t blown your mind enough for one
day!